[Music]
foreign
luck and risk are two of the most
important words for anybody who wants to
be great but they kind of I think for
most people feel like it's something
that's outside of your control right
luck is this magical thing that either
happens to you or it doesn't or uh risk
is this thing that you either get
screwed by or you don't and I don't
think that's true I think there's a lot
more to risk and luck than most people
recognize it's the same way that uh I
think Eskimos have like 40 or 50 words
for snow right when we see something
just falling from the sky that's white
and fluffy we just think that's snow
whereas they have 40 or 50 different
words to describe the different types of
snow as you would if you lived in an
extremely snowy environment you would
develop that vocabulary and so similarly
for an entrepreneur who is going in an
environment of trying to make great
success happen maybe we need some Nuance
some differentiation between the
different types of luck the different
flavors of risk and so that's what I'm
gonna tell you today these are the four
flavors of luck and the four flavors of
risk let's start with luck so so this I
got from Mark Andreessen back in the day
he had a Blog that he used to keep up
it's down now
there's an archive of it up online
somewhere called PM archive and I still
remember reading this post like you know
10 years ago and it was about the four
different types of luck I think he
originally read it in some book and um
the low the levels of luck are as
follows level one is called Blind luck
you just sit around you get struck by
lightning and um you know you didn't do
anything you just happened to be you and
it's not something you can count on
either right so this is blind luck and
you know for me I was just born with the
use of my my limbs and I was born
healthy I was born in the right country
and
um you know I remember one time my
cousin gave me a bunch of raffle tickets
that he had bought he gave it gave it to
all of our cousins and I ended up
winning this dolly painting out of uh
out of the raffle I didn't I literally
didn't do anything I just sat there he
handed me a ticket my ticket happened to
win and so um that's an example of blind
luck that's level one okay can't do much
with that because it's sort of uh it's
either gonna happen or it's not the next
one you can increase the odds of of luck
in your favor by going to level two
level two is what the the phrase around
fortune favors the bold and it's the
same as the the one above it's sort of a
lucky chance but you increase the odds
of it happening by adding motion or
action to the mix so you're doing a
bunch of stuff you're running around you
know if the first one is you're standing
in place and lightning strikes you this
one you're running around all over the
place kicking up dust stirring up the
pot and something happens as a result of
your motion your motion increased the
surface area you were covering where you
might happen to get lucky and so this is
a chance encounter uh right maybe you're
just out and about and in doing so you
bump into somebody who's really
interesting and opens up some
opportunity for you and um there's a
phrase uh there's a quote that I like
which is you know I've never heard of
someone stumbling onto something good
while sitting down and this just
emphasizes the importance of Simply
taking a bunch of action uh of being out
there of of having some motion and um
and carrying with you some good vibes so
that good things happen in the way so
that's level two motion Crea you know
fortune favors the Bold
level three this is where it starts to
get interesting this is Chance favors
the prepared mind right so this is where
you notice that something lucky has
happened where other people may not have
noticed and it is your years of
preparation of looking at things to even
understand this so any investor knows
this right you look at a hundred deals
it's not because all 100 are gonna be
good it's so that when that 101st deal
comes that really has killer metrics
you're able to recognize that that deal
is unique that that price is a fantastic
price so these metrics are off the
charts because you have a benchmark of
what normal looks like this also happens
in science I mean there's an amazing
story about the the discovery of
penicillin right this drug that has
saved millions and millions of lives in
the course of history well the way it
was discovered was
um the scientist who was studying he uh
just noticed that some mold had fallen
on his petri dish and his accident uh
right so that was not in his country was
not the result of his action but he was
he had a prepared mind he noted
that around the mold in the petri dish
no bacteria was growing they started to
wonder maybe there's something about
this mold that kills bacteria and he
wrote that down he tried to convince
others of it and nobody cared no none of
his peers cared and then you know 10
years go by before somebody else picks
up this paper and says huh that's weird
that the sort of the staph bacteria was
not growing around this mold the mold
seemed to kill staff bacteria what I
wonder if we could go back and revisit
that and then they tried to try to
actually revisit it so they had the
prepared mind to read that paper and
notice huh
there's something interesting there and
so that is luck favoring the prepared
mind
um the last one the level four luck is
luck finds you so this is reputational
luck you've heard me on this podcast say
before that my goal with this podcast is
not to become well known all right I'm
not trying to be famous I'm trying to be
known well meaning I just try to put my
brain and my the things I'm most into
out there on blast so that people who
are like-minded will come find me people
who are building you know startups in
that space will come find me and I can
invest them people who are um you know
using a product that they know that I
love they'll share it with me right
that's the value that I get back out of
this because I'm well known my
reputation brings me some luck and so uh
the example I think Naval gives of this
he says imagine you were known as the
best deep sea scuba diver in the world
right you are amazing at Deep Sea Dives
you're just sitting on your couch one
day you're not doing anything and the
phone rings and somebody calls you and
says we've discovered a treasure off the
coast of India buried deep down below
will you come help us retrieve it and
you get to share you know whatever 25 uh
of whatever we find so now you your
reputation has caused you to find a
treasure right luck has found you your
reputation of being a great person at
doing X will cause people to come find
you and so um you know we just did a
podcast with Kevin Rose and he talked
about this with Twitter he had the
prepared mind to notice that Twitter was
going to be a big deal and he's very
humble like other Investments he says
you know I don't know you just I just
wrote the check I like the person it
turned out well but for Twitter I said
did you know it was a it's going to be a
big winner and he goes I thought it was
the next big thing he goes because I had
seen blank blank like I was using it and
I noticed man this thing has really
given me this feeling imagine I'm just a
little Tech celebrity imagine if real
celebrities got a hold of this this is
going to be crazy and like he noticed
that Facebook and all the social
networks before this were all based on
this idea of a friend where I had to
request to follow you and you had to
accept it in order for me to see your
content and that Twitter this new thing
that everybody else was making fun I've
had had one new feature which was it was
one directional I could just follow you
and you didn't have to give me approval
and he goes wow that's going to be
amazing for celebrities so that was luck
you know the prepared mind he then took
action he reaches out to Evan he says
I'd love to invest
oh sorry the round is closed um sorry
about that so he's turned away
but this is where his reputation allowed
him to get lucky
a couple weeks later EV calls back and
says hey uh you asked about investing
right you know we have this engineer
who's leaving he wants to sell some of
his shares we can you know you could buy
his if you want right I'll let you in
because it's you because I love I like
you I like the way you are I think you
have a good eye for product you're
really active on Twitter
um and I know you really believe in this
you've made that well known well here
you go here's your opportunity and that
25 000 turns into you know 100 million
dollar plus payday that's luck finding
you
our software is the worst have you heard
of HubSpot see most crms are a cobble
together mess but HubSpot is easy to
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
so those are the four levels of luck now
let's talk about the four levels of risk
the four these are not levels these are
more flavors of risk so the first one
the first risk or I'll put it
differently
people think the big risk is you go and
do something crazy right I'm gonna go
jump out of a plane uh skydiving I'm
gonna go invest all my money into crypto
right
those are obvious risks but because
they're obvious risk people don't always
take them or they take a lot of
precaution with it so
um most people don't go skydiving they
say that that sounds risky so I'm not
gonna do it and even the people who do
they go with an instructor who's done
thousands of things before and they make
sure that the place has good reviews and
that is a good track record and they say
okay great I'll jump out of this with a
parachute with it with a professional so
they they do things to mitigate risk so
I think you know same thing with crypto
oh you're investing in crypto but you're
only investing one percent five percent
ten percent some smallish percent of
your net worth into this risky thing
because it was obviously risky so the
things that are obviously risky don't
actually trip you up it's the things
that are not obviously risky so an
example of that would be
um everybody before you know 2008
generally thought that mortgages and the
housing market was a pretty safe
industry to bet in uh to invest in and
that's why if you ever watch The Big
Short you know all these mortgages were
highly rated uh debt and in actuality
they were much riskier than people
realized and that's what caused the
global financial crisis was because
there was this huge there was this risk
that people did not identify as risky
they thought it was safe but actually it
was risky and they therefore relied too
much on it took out too much leverage
blah blah and then you get disasters and
so that's the first thing to recognize
about risk is risk is not just the
things you think about so here's some of
the Hidden types of risk or different
flavors that you should think about the
first one is mediocrity
because when most people go into a job
or a business that they want to start
they think that their risk is failure
that I'll try this and it's going to
totally Crash and Burn and in actuality
at least for most people in America
that's not that painful of a risk you
waste a little bit of time but it failed
it you know crashed and burned and you
can move on and you learned a lesson and
you have a story to tell and you might
have met some people along the way
you've built some skills and so you
actually don't take that much risk doing
it and you generally will you know not
put too much money into something at
that stage
so that's one version of failing with us
let's say a startup or a job but the
other version that I think is much more
sneaky and Much More Much plagues many
more people is mediocrity which is the
risk of having something that's just
okay it's not bad enough to obviously
fail nor is it good enough to be amazing
and so the risk is that you're wasting
your most valuable asset your time on
something that is not great and so if
you listen to this podcast you're the
type of person that wants greatness out
of your life then the biggest risk to
you is mediocrity because failing is
fine you'll just try another thing
you'll try something else but something
that's just all right it's not great but
not bad enough to fail is going to
deprive you of your most valuable asset
your time so mediocrity is the first
flavor of risk to identify in what way
are you just settling for a bad
relationship
um or a just okay relationship a just
okay job a just okay level of traction
at your startup that is one risk the
next one
safety
safety is a risk okay how is safety a
risk well there's a risk in not taking
enough risk so you got to ask yourself
I have a dream I have an ambition I have
a goal that I'm trying to get myself to
if I keep doing things the way that I'm
currently doing them right in my comfort
zone where I am safe I'm not taking any
risk right now is it going to lead to my
dream right am I on path am I on track
am I is my trajectory taking me to where
I'm trying to go because if not then the
safety you have now is actually putting
your dream at risk your goal at risk so
people usually think am I putting myself
currently at risk but what you want to
think about is am I putting my dream at
risk am I putting my future success at
risk by playing it safe now okay so
that's the second one playing it too
safe
the third risk is the Eyes Wide Shut
risk that's the one I talked about with
the mortgages right
it's one thing when you go in Eyes Wide
Open you say oh I'm doing this thing but
it's risky so therefore I'm not going to
bet it all and I'm gonna take some
precautions
that's eyes wide open but what about
Eyes Wide Shut what happens if you uh
you think something is safe but it's not
you trust the wrong person and you bet
it all or you think that housing is safe
and so you're super levered up
um you think that this is too big to
fail but in fact it is not and so
um Eyes Wide Shut risk you want to ask
yourself what am I assuming is safe
that may not actually be safe
um the last one is Market risk
executional risk versus technical risk
these are like the eskimos having 50
words for snow there are many different
types of risk in business so Market risk
is trying to figure out will does
anybody even want this at my start my
previous startup you know the studio I
worked at Monkey Inferno we were
building we had every resource available
we had all the money we wanted we had
team of Engineers that were super smart
freedom to work on whatever we wanted
but the boundary was we got to work on
something in consumer and it shifted
towards social and when we try to build
the next social app you're taking on
massive amounts of Market risk does
anybody want your thing is this going to
be the next Twitter the next Snapchat et
cetera that was massive Market risk
um you know it didn't matter that we had
a killer teamwork we could build a
killer product
um because Market risk means if people
don't actually want your well-made app
it multiplies it by zero and um so the
next thing is then you take friends like
um enduring Ventures or Cody Sanchez and
people who buy cash flowing businesses
that's fantastic they're not taking
Market risk the market has already
proven that they want that business they
want that product it's already cash
flowing so they take executional risk
they pay a price maybe three four five
times
um earnings and they're taking
executional risk that can I improve the
business can I improve through
executional efficiencies or or growing
you know growing revenue or reducing
costs can I improve this business so
they take executional risk you know when
I buy this owner out is the whole thing
gonna fall over or can we continue to
execute so they take they don't take
Market risk they take execution risk and
then you have people who are people who
I invest in for my startups that often
take technical risks so the example I
give of this is a pizza making robot
let's say that I'm Domino's pizza and a
startup comes to me and says hey we have
a robot that will replace that worker
you have in the back that's sitting
there he's checking his phones picking
his nose and he's calling in sick every
fourth day and um you know he's the one
who's supposed to take the dough put it
in the oven put the cheese and sauce on
it and put it in the box so here's the
deal I have a robot that will put a
perfectly circular dough with the
perfect thickness that you specify or
add the exact amount of cheese never
waste waste too much too much extra
cheese it'll bake it to the exact amount
of time every single time it'll never
call in sick it can work 24 7 and um and
it'll never complain and ask for a raise
okay that's this robot so there's if you
could deliver such a product it would be
essentially Zero Market risk
um because of course dominoes would want
to replace more expensive labor that is
harder to manage with something that is
cheaper and easier to manage of course
they would do that so the only question
is can you make a robot that actually
delivers on that promise reliably right
can you actually deliver the promise
that's technical risk this is with a lot
of Bio biotech pharmaceutical
um and like you know you know defense
contracts there's things like that where
they're taking technical risk can they
can they actually make a product that
lives up to the spec and so you got to
know what type of risk are you taking so
those are the four types mediocrity the
biggest risk of all
safety not taking enough risk Eyes Wide
Shut risk that's assuming something is
safe when in actuality it's riskier than
you think and the last one is knowing
whether you're you're attempting to take
Market risk execution risk or technical
risk and being uh being honest with
yourself about what type of risk you're
taking when you go into this endeavor
the goal is not to avoid risk it's to
understand it and then work your way
around it all right I think that's it
um instead of one question Friday I did
framework Friday let me know what you
think I'm Sean VP on Twitter that's
s-h-a-a-n-v-p on Twitter and so you can
find me there let me know what you think
about it framework Friday is in the
books all right have a good weekend
foreign
[Music]